alors évidemment vous le venez de lire
la question que beaucoup se posent ce
convoi de la liberté prémices du retour
des gilet jaune le gouvernement a t-il
raison de craindre à nouveau mouvement
d'ampleur le débat est ouvert et on
attend évidemment aussi vos avis sur le
conte télégramme d'ayrté france et leurs
dons de notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau eric revel éditorialistes rt
france bonsoir et rigueur si d'être avec
nous à nos côtés également
nicolas vidal et nettoyer certes et
france vaut aussi nicolas vidal un bon
soir france 4 boeuf délégué
départemental du modem dans le nord
bonsoir france 80 merci d'être là alors
nicolas vidal vous suivez ce mouvement
vous serez d'ailleurs demain au départ
de lyon dans votre émission radio
d'ailleurs vous avez reçu aussi des
canadiens qui ont participé à ce
mouvement initial au canada comment vous
définiriez justement ce mouvement ben
oui c'est venu ruiner c'est extrêmement
intéressant on avait suivi gilet jaune
bien sûr la passerelle peut se faire si
la question centrale que je me pose mon
recevant effectivement les canadiens les
québécois est maintenant les
porte-paroles de convois france moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est l'aspect politique
c'est l'aspect populaire est la question
que je me pose depuis le début je ne
vous le cache pas je pense qu'elle est à
double niveau et surtout à un niveau
supérieur à tout ça au delà des
restrictions sanitaires de cette révolte
là c'était une attitude pour reprendre
les mots de guérilla talent ce qui se
pose comme question c'est pourquoi ce
qu'on veut la liberté se fit il a deux
mois la présidentielle parce qu'on
pourrait se dire les gens pourraient
attendre les deux mois et finalement
estimé qu'il faut changer de président
république et le gouvernement pourra
pour avoir des délibérations de mesures
mais aujourd'hui je pense que la
question est beaucoup plus profonde que
ça pour moi le convoi de liberté au delà
de crise sanitaire c'est aussi la
faillie démocratique de la classe
politique pourquoi parce que la plupart
des partis politiques ont perdu quoi ils
ont perdu la fonction tribunitienne
finalement de recueillir un suffrage
important est de porter des voix qui
sont dissidente bilan tendu et ça ça me
semble extrêmement extrêmement
extrêmement important et finalement on
se rend compte que peut-être que les
français parce qu'il faut lire s'était
fait nommer rue les gens qui sont sur la
route ce soir un peu partout sur les
aires d'autoroutes et demain c'est la
partie immergée de l'iceberg selon lui
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui les
soutiennent et nous on le voit dans les
réseaux nous avons dans les appels que
nous avons dans les informations nous
avons il ya beaucoup de jours ci qu'ils
peuvent pas monter à paris pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont du travail mais aussi
notant le parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'argent on ça coûte cher de monter à
paris bien entendu se loger tous donc
il ya le prix du carburant on va vous
redonner la parole évidemment essayer de
comprendre à ce mouvement qui est un
petit peu de nouveau en tout cas peau
pour nous et eric revel il faut
s'attendre à un mouvement de grande
ampleur selon vous à leur star no ce que
nous disait nicolas vidal il ya vraiment
une colère qui gronde il ya plusieurs
origines à ce mouvement potentiel il y a
on parlait de déficit démocratique est
le pass vaccinale mais dont on sait qui
va être sans doute supprimés dans
quelques semaines juste avant évidemment
l'élection présidentielle mais il ya
aussi la question du pouvoir d'achat
globalement et en fait ce mouvement peut
se cristalliser autour de plusieurs
thèmes
celui des libertés très bien il savait
le convoi de liberté mais aussi celui
mais aussi celui du pouvoir d'achat et
ça c'est aussi une thématique
extrêmement forte je pense la flambée du
prix des carburants n'a fait que
s'accroître
ce cet écueil social pour le
gouvernement et je ne sais pas si le
mouvement va prendre ou ne va pas
prendre mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
pour l'instant ils s'invitent très
clairement dans la campagne
présidentielle d'ailleurs je ne pense
pas je n'imagine pas que le président de
la république se déclare candidat avant
de voir si ce mouvement prendra ont pas
de l'ampleur après il ya deux hypothèses
ce mouvement prend de l'ampleur et ça
devient un sujet politique de premier
plan pour le président la république qui
non seulement devra
proposer un projet mais devra aussi
expliquer son bilan et on termes de
pouvoir d'achat plusieurs rapports ont
montré que bon les plus riches étaient
plutôt enrichi en france mais que les
plus pauvres avaient
décrocher mais il ya aussi une autre
hypothèse c'est que si ce mouvement
prend
emmanuel macron candidat il aura besoin
de solidifier sa base et pour une partie
de sa base la fermeté peut-être à driver
important pour sa candidature beaucoup
de gens se disent mais si c'est passé
moi l'expression de nouveau un peu le
bordel extra
l'économie française
le chef de l'état va être amoindrie et
peut voir les choses comme ça mais on
peut se dire aussi qu'une partie de
l'électorat des manuels macro et des
français en général sont plutôt pour
l'ordre et la fermeté donc peut-être
opposera t-il comme il l'a fait avec les
débordements qu on a connu ce moment des
gilet jaune il opposera à une
manifestation qui prendrait de l'ampleur
la fermeté pour assumer assuré son
statut de chef de l'état
on parle également des conséquences
économiques parce qu'on a vu ces
cortèges ces blocages au canada là on
voit d'un oeil un petit peu circonspect
l'arrivée à paris ça ferait certainement
très mal à l'économie qui a déjà
beaucoup souffert si ce mouvement devait
prendre de l'ampleur en tant que membre
d'une certaine manière de la majorité
est ce que vous êtes un chievo
il est difficile de dire en les pas si
effectivement ces convois s'arrêteront à
paris il dans les déclarations certains
ont fait est que j'ai lu et compris sur
votre site ils n'ont pas l'intention de
bloquer la capitale mais plutôt de de la
traverser pour se rendre à bruxelles
incidemment d'ailleurs c'est l'occasion
pour moi de souligner que les peuples
sont souvent en avance car certaines de
leurs leaders puisque vous voyez que
c'est à bruxelles que dans un mouvement
européen
les protestataires se réunissent ce
pourrait être une leçon intéressante à
méditer pour les souverainistes
pour le reste j'ai trouvé des propos
tout à fait intéressant dans les deux
intervenants précédents je suis d'accord
avec le fait qu'il y a incontestablement
une crise démocratique et qu'il faut y
remédier et vous savez que le modem à
faire un certain nombre de propositions
et de longue date pour ce faire
particulièrement le fait
qu'effectivement ça se produise la
campagne
présidentielle montre que malgré ce
moment de démocratie et bien il y
assemble de français qui ne se
reconnaissent pas de façon anticipée en
quelque sorte donc il faut vraiment s'en
préoccuper dans le résultat quel qu'il
soit au fond la question du pouvoir
d'achat kiwi sera centrale évidemment et
il faut absolument travailler sur cette
question du pouvoir d'achat des classes
populaires c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui de vous le dire ce qu'il va
se passer mais en tous les cas ce que
j'ai lu ce que j'ai entendu avant de
vous rejoindre sur ce plateau c'est que
pour l'instant tous les cas les
intentions sont tout à fait démocratique
une dernière chose qui est intéressante
monsieur ciotti a dit qu'il n'était pas
d'accord avec ces manifestations tandis
que monsieur polanski et parlementaires
de la france insoumise lui appelle ses
militants à participer
encore une fois ce sont les populistes
qui tentent de semer le désordre contre
les valeurs démocratiques que nous
partageons même avec nos cieux sciatique
qui est un démocrate même s'il est
éloigné positions politiques et en a un
autre en tons kaki a pas l'air tellement
d'accord au casting qui nous divise pas
et se méfier c'est gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur je vous propose
de l'écouter
nous prenons les choses au sérieux ce
qui est certain c'est que nous mettons
les moyens de renseignement et d'action
si jamais des gens voulaient bloquer la
liberté des uns et des autres surtout en
accès à la capitale donc les moyens sont
importants la réponse de l'état sera
extrêmement ferme si c'est le cas les
policiers et les gendarmes sont très
mobilisés et nous prendrons nos
responsabilités pour ne jamais laisser
entraver la liberté de circulation voilà
on voit les convoyeurs de la liberté
sont prévenus par le ministre de
l'intérieur on a évidemment tous en tête
ces manifestations avec les gilet jaune
qui ne se seront pas toujours bien passé
notamment à paris pourtant comme on l'a
dit ce moment n'appelle pas à des
actions de blocage ans est très
pacifique c'est plutôt bon enfant
d'après ce qu'on a pu lire pourquoi
cette ce discours d'affrontements du
gouvernement nicolas vidal selon vous
bien le gouvernement il n'a tiré aucun
enseignement de la crise et gilet jaune
le gouvernement d'attirer au conseil
enseignement cheminement de la perte du
pouvoir d'achat la paupérisation de la
précarisation et ça c'est quand même
assez étonnant et d'ailleurs vous le
voyez bien gérald darmanin il parle de
quoi il parle de l'île de france et de
paris nous voyons bien là la fracture
une nouvelle fois entre la france
périphérique la france d'aider les
jeunes la france qui est aux quatre
coins du royaume de france et de navarre
et le pouvoir en place mais entendu et
vous avez raison de le noter c'est
francis sincèrement que ceux des
français les français qui sont
actuellement sur les routes cj des
jeunes aussi qui seront là et des
citoyens lambda français moyens mais ils
entendus dont je fais partie ils n'ont
aucune aspiration révolutionnaire soyons
très clairs ils n'ont aucune aspiration
séditieuse ou factieuses donc je crois
qu'il faut toujours revenir à ça malgré
ses problèmes c'est la hauteur de 8 par
rapport à ça et moi ce qui m'inquiète
énormément et ça m'avait inquiété de la
ville et gilet jaune bien entendu je
connais bien ces mouvements c'est
vraiment la perte de confiance et la
perte surtout de la légitimité politique
et ça c'est gravissime parce que c'est
une faille dans notre démocratie si
aujourd'hui n'est pas résolu on voit que
la classe politique même regardez
monsieur philippot qui avait prévu lui
de faire qui a fait de grandes
manifestations finalement on voit que là
dessus il est même lui même il est
débordé finalement par ce mouvement
citoyen donc on voit bien qu'il ya une
fracture de plus en plus béantes une
alice est abyssal entre des millions de
français où des centaines de français
partie immergée de l'iceberg et la
classe politique
et ça c'est et le pouvoir en place ne
comprend toujours pas la situation admet
mme à 2 - la présidentielle qui sont ils
ces convoyeurs de la liberté on va
justement leur poser la question on va
leur donner la parole on est en direct
tout de suite avec régine briquet aux
retraités qui participent à ce qu'on
voit bonsoir madame merci de nous
apporter votre témoignage ce soir
pourquoi avoir rejoint le mouvement
nous avons été traités de sous citoyens
par le suma cour avait montré qu on
n'est pas déçu sous citoyens je voudrais
déjà fait un rectificatif et vous lire
le comité officiel de convois france ce
sont les raisons pour lesquelles nous
allons nous mettre à la différence de
paris ensuite ceux qui le souhaitent
pourront aller dans paris pour rejoindre
les manifestations qu'il souhaite
puisque rats plusieurs manifestations
le communiqué officiel
elle n'y en a pas d'autre et les
citoyens entendent récupérer leur
liberté leurs droits fondamentaux
l'accès inconditionnel aux soins à
l'éducation à la culture
leur respect des valeurs essentielles de
notre constitution
sovo inscrit 6 des enfants et de la
jeunesse ce sont-là maltraitances subies
quotidiennement vous voyez bien que
derrière ces revendications nous ne
parlons absolument pas des
revendications qu'on présentait les
gilets jaunes
rémy hunter responsable et nicolas que
j'ai vu en vidéo ya pas longtemps avec
maria et marisa il sait très bien que ce
mouvement est totalement pacifique et
apolitique
alors c'est vrai qu'un homme politique
qui a contacté un haut responsable il a
dit on vous attend philippon a dit on
vise à temps et la nôtre responsable a
bien répondu non c'est vous qui nous
rejoignent et de façon neutre il n'y a
aucune tendance politique dans ce convoi
régine répondent aux messages pas de
tendance politique mais ce qui est
intéressant parce qu'aujourd'hui voilà
on s'est beaucoup posé la question ici
ou là de savoir si ce mouvement était un
nouveau mouvement des gilet jaune vous
dites maintenant nous ce sont nos
revendications ce que vous venez de nous
lire le communiqué sauf que sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien il ya des
anciens j'ai les jambes qui se sont
greffés on va d'ailleurs certainement
les entendra on les a déjà entendus
notamment sur les questions du pouvoir
d'achat ça vous n'êtes pas vraiment
d'accord ou ou tout simplement cesser un
mouvement qui semble peut être échappé
aux organisateurs et qui prend de
l'ampleur avec d'autres revendications
d'autres mécontentements
non c'est une confusion qu'il ya dans
les ce prix parce qu'il est vrai que les
gilets jaunes se sont beaucoup battus
mais le but ce n'est pas les
revendications du gilet jaune même si
elles sont justifiées mais normalement
il n'ya aucune revendication et c'est
vrai que sur les réseaux il y à une
confusion c'est pour ça que j'ai tenu à
vous lier le communiqué officiel chaque
personne va à cette manifestation on va
dire que ce passe chaque personne
indépendante qui retrouve un ensemble de
personnes on parle pas politique du tout
mais nous ce sont politisées pardonnez
moi mais c'était tout simplement départ
dvd simple citoyen français qui parlait
pouvoir d'achat ça veut dire que ça a
été dévoyé selon vous et qu'ils se sont
un peu politisée vous réfutez leur
présence aujourd'hui
non jeu réussit pas du tout leur
présence on est très contents qu'il soit
là évidemment c'est il faut savoir que
les médias il faut au moins je regarde
tous les médias et je passe mon temps à
calmer a rectifié sur les réseaux menthe
absolument / 7 / ont menti sur les
gilets jaunes pour les discréditer et
comme ils essayent de discréditer et ils
appellent déjà il annonce déjà les
manifestations mais je crois qu'à paris
ils s'attendent pas cet événement
pacifique
est un événement pacifique et non
politisée on va pouvoir empêcher les
banderoles on va pas pouvoir empêcher
des gens avec des revendications sur le
sur le pouvoir d'achat ce n'est pas
l'objectif principal
de cette manifestation
pacifique qui de demandes que le retour
aux libertés merci en tout cas régime
briquettes de long pour avoir apporter
votre témoignage eric revel c'est assez
intéressant puisque régime briquettes
fait partie effectivement de l'origine
en tout cas en france de ce mouvement
plusieurs choses à retenir dans ce
qu'elle a dit oui plusieurs choses à
retenir ce mouvement se veut
indépendant de solides et gilet jaune ce
qui est assez étonnant c'est le moment
où ça arrive quand même parce que vous
avez sans doute entendu olivier ferrand
je crois ou le porte parole du
gouvernement expliqué que d'ici quelques
semaines on avait une clause de revoyure
et que sans doute le pass vaccinale
allait être mis de côté donc si c'est
juste sur la question des libertés et
des contraintes sanitaires qui ont été
imposées aux français on se demande
pourquoi quelques jours peut-être à
quelques semaines ce mouvement prendrait
une telle ampleur moi je continue de
penser qu'il peut y avoir une une
cristallisation très forte mais juste
sur le déficit démocratique si vous
permettez stéphanie tout à l'heure le
représentant du modem pardonnez moi
monsieur disait je suis d'accord avec
cette analyse ya un déficit démocratique
et nous au modem nous avons proposé
beaucoup de choses oui votre leader
françois bayrou a proposé beaucoup de
choses et je pense notamment à la
proportionnelle pour les élections
législatives qui suivront l'élection
présidentielle mais de toutes ces
propositions
emmanuel macron n'en a tenu retenue
aucune
françois faber pas de réponse vous le
déplorez j'imagine
oui je nous ne lâcherons pas nous
finirons bien par y arriver il faut
quand même dire aussi la vérité c'est
que les centristes sont ses seuls à
réclamer par exemple la proportionnelle
une grande partie de la gauche et plus
encore de la droite qui est hostile
depuis toujours donc nous ne serons pas
trop si monsieur revel soutenir et aider
les bienvenus je veux dire ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il ya une élection
présidentielle et ya des élections
législatives quoique ce que quoique
quoique va être le résultat l'élection
présidentielle il ya des législatives
derrière et des candidats qui seraient
présents second tour qui ferait des
scores importants qu'ils soient de
l'extrême droite de la droite nationale
ou de l'extrême gauche pour beaucoup de
français ça apparaîtra comme totalement
anachronique voir comme un un sujet de
colère supplémentaires si tous ces gens
là toutes ces voix là c'est millions de
voix ne sont représentés que par une
poignée de députés
alors on va pas c'était intéressant
femme message mais c'est vrai que le
débat était davantage sur les convoyeurs
de liberté vous quand vous entendez
madame ricaine aulas nous dire bon ou
c'est sur les libertés les gilet jaune
dont a bien compris effectivement
qu'elle ne souhaitait pas être récupéré
entre guillemets mais est-ce que selon
vous ça comme on le disait ça ne couvre
pas une colère plus grande on a vu que
voilà envers et contre tout et gilet
jaune sont en train de rejoindre ce
mouvement va en parler d'eric nicolas
vidal après
eric revel à raison évidemment
s'il s'agit uniquement des
revendications que cette dame a présenté
avec une conviction tout à fait sincère
au fond fin mars début avril le problème
serait réglé or il faut être réaliste
une grande partie des manifestants vont
manifester pour des raisons liées au
pouvoir d'achat et aux difficultés
sociales donc c'est aussi à celle pas
qu'il faut répondre et il faut respecter
leur demande bien évidemment et je
voudrais répondre à cet égard à votre
autre éditorialiste
il disait gérald darmanin n'a pas
compris il veut protéger paris n'a pas
compris que ça se passe en province mais
écoutez je serai la semaine prochaine un
jacut de la mer charmante bourgade des
côtes d'armor il me semble improbable
que les convois de la liberté bloquent
le centre de saint jacut de la mer de
sorte que évidemment quand on pense à
paris parce que les convois se dit père
paris s il se dirigeait vers saint jacut
penserait à sacré de la mecque là ça
n'est pas un déni de reconnaissance de
la province
quand on songe à l'endroit où se
dirigent ces convois nicolas vidal quand
vous avez entendu effectivement celle
d'amman où parler de liberté
vous témoignez il n'y a pas que ce mode
horde ans n'en déplaise peut-être aux
organisateurs initiaux de ce mouvement
qui peut être prendre l'ampleur et qui
les dépasse un petit peu mais vous avez
raison ce qui est intéressant de voir
c'est que pendant que nous corriger les
jeunes et j'ai fait plusieurs fois
l'expérience et pendant ce mouvement là
qui est en train de naître c'est toute
une partie de france est finalement qui
sont 60 senti citoyens ils sont
redevenus citoyens pourquoi ils seront
devenus citoyens parce que finalement
kong traite de sous-citoyens cas
emmanuel macouin cette phrase terrible
cette violence verbale envers des
millions de gens il ya des gens
aujourd'hui ouvre les yeux et qui se
disent mais qu'est-ce qui est être un
citoyen et ça c'est vraiment intéressant
et je vous donnais une année je
regardais tout à l'heure de libye les
convois qui serait de même j'ai eu un
peu regardez et vous voyez que
finalement ça va très loin parce que si
vous regardez les marques des voitures
notamment sur le départ du convoi de
nice vous voyez que les marques de
voitures elles sont celles de cadres
supérieurs donc vous voyez bien que
finalement il ya eu un basculement cette
violence verbale qui a eu les manuels
macron quidam ici veut dire des sous
citoyens et il ya des gens qui se sont
réveillées donc ça fait deux vagues
entre les gilet jaune et cette crise
d'art il ya aussi ce basculement de gens
qui étaient les français mais qui était
pas qu'ils considéraient pas la vie
publique clients comme importante qui
est aujourd'hui comme toutes les
politiques surtout si les mesures
sanitaires ils sont ils sont saisis de
la question à citoyenneté y aujourd'hui
il monte vraiment à paris ou de moutier
mais peut-être à bruxelles et ça c'est
intéressant dans peut-être pas le temps
d'en parler mais c'est intéressant mais
finalement ce mouvement est très très
large parce que les gens se sont sentis
violente et ils se sont sentis abîmée
stéphanie sur cette notion de sous
citoyens et ça pour le chef de l'état
c'est très très grave il ya eu une
grosse polémique mais je pense qu'elle
aurait dû être encore plus massive
concrètement et aujourd'hui nous avons
ce qu'on veut la liberté aussi pour
reprendre la dignité la liberté et la
dignité voilà eric revel c'est vrai que
pourquoi bruxelles on sait que beaucoup
de décisions se prennent à bruxelles
mais enfin quand on
manifestent contre les libertés c'est au
niveau national auquel ça se fait on a
entendu d'ailleurs lévriers natale
défendre son bilan en disant voilà ça a
été peut-être moins pire que dans les
autres pays européens pourquoi bruxelles
je pense que c'est assez intéressant
parce que vous avez comme tout un camp
souverainiste en france qui défend
l'idée que nous basculons peu ou prou
dans une europe fédérale que les
français savent qu'on transpose des
directives bruxelloise dans les droits
nationaux donc dans le droit français et
ça me donne le sentiment mais il
faudrait les interroger que aujourd'hui
c'est ce convoi de la liberté qui
devrait donc se rendre à bruxelles
fait comme si en fait les décisions
n'étaient plus prises par les pays par
les états mais par la commission de
bruxelles donc c'est tout à fait qu'ils
aient bien compris c'est tout un tas
sans peut-être aussi que différents
convois parce que il se passe aussi à
peu près la même chose aux pays bas et
dans le pays peut-être que tous ces
convois veulent aussi convergé vers un
point central ils vont pas traversé tous
les pays et que bruxelles leur semble
être le centre de décision
incontournable mais c'est intéressant au
moment où l'on parle de de souveraineté
face à une europe fédérale de voir que
ces gens vont s'y rendre et quand même
une question qui est pas du tout cynique
de ma part mais on parle beaucoup de la
question du pouvoir d'achat et de
l'envolée des carburants il va quand
même falloir que tous ces gens m'aident
beaucoup d'essence dans leur voiture
s'ils veulent aller au bout de leur
convoi effectivement et ça risque de
coûter cher d'ailleurs je voudrais vous
faire écouter la réaction propose de
pouvoir d'achat élevé du carburant d'un
ancien gilet jaune et pierre réagi à ce
mouvement
de liberté et rideaux et
si macro est réélu je pense que les
gilet jaune ce sera encore pire que ce
qu'il y a eu lie à trois ans
je soutiens le convoi de la liberté mais
je trouve que c'est un petit peu léger
au niveau des revendications parce qu'il
ya tellement de choses qui ne vont pas
en ce moment plus que le pass sanitaires
et toutes ces choses là il y à l'essence
qui flambent plein d'augmentation plein
d'autres choses
la question du pouvoir d'achat
thème évidemment la campagne
présidentielle vous l'affrontez
avec son doudou t pensez vous mais
écoutez je vous rappel pour celles et
ceux qui l'auraient oublié qu'avant la
crise donne le modem à plusieurs
reprises s'était élevée en se disant
l'aide sociale de l'autorité en disant
qu'il fait so lu ment une politique plus
sociale ensuite il y a eu évidemment
elle est salutaire et tout cela écarte
mais il est incontestable qu'il faudra
s'il avait le maquereau est réélu ce que
nous souhaitons bien évidemment
mouvement démocrate il faudra une
politique sociale et il faudra prendre
en compte effectivement les aspirations
des classes populaires c'est c'est bien
évident
moi je vais être tout à fait objective
comme je me suis très souvent et tout le
temps c'est que
les français qui souvent on montre du
doigt l'état trop dispendieux avec trop
de fonctionnaires ces mêmes français y
imagine que c'est l'état qui imposerait
aux entreprises une augmentation des
salaires or par définition c'est la
politique salariale des entreprises
alors il ya deux leviers quand même pour
l'état il ya évidemment augmenter le
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires qui
est gelé depuis beaucoup d'années et
puis la deuxième possibilité c'est
augmenter le niveau du salaire minimum
mais mais il ya deux âmes ont avisé que
écueil très fort aujourd'hui si vous
augmentez le salaire minimum d'abord
c'est une répercussion sur l'ensemble de
la grille salariale de l'entreprise et
j'ajoute que nous sommes dans une
période d'inflation réel et d'inflation
sous jacente très importante et que même
si je ne mets pas du tout de côté la
question du pouvoir d'achat il faut
quand même s'interroger parce qu'une
augmentation généralisée des salaires ça
rend plus chères la production et ça
augmente l'inflation donc l'impression
qu'on pourrait avoir avec une
augmentation de son salaire d'avoir
davantage de pouvoir d'achat peut-être
rattrapé par une passion plus forte qui
rognera au contraire votre pouvoir
d'achat l'occasion évidemment de revenir
sur ce thème du pouvoir d'achat très
longuement pendant cette campagne
présidentielle et notamment avec vous
eric revel merci à vous en octobre
nicolas vidal eric revel d'avoir était
avec nous pour ce décryptage